lawmakers demanding an investigation
into what was potentially the world's
first coronavirus super spreader event
the washington post reports more than 9
000 athletes attended the military world
games in wuhan china
in october 2019 including 280 from the
united states
many of them complained about covet-like
symptoms two
months before china even acknowledged
the virus's existence
it comes amid concerns that coronavirus
leaked from a research lab there
here's what texas congressman michael
burgess told maria bartoromo
last week
will there be any accountability for the
ccp allowing this
deadly disease to escape its borders and
covering it up
my opinion is there just simply has to
be and whether that's done on the trade
front whether that's done on
some type of of remuneration that has to
occur
with this illness different from sars 1
20 years ago remember there there was a
jump from a bat to a civic cat
to then to people this one there was no
intermediary
which really really does point to the
fact lab manufacturer lab release
accidental on purpose that will have to
be determined
kansas republican senator roger marshall
wrote to secretary xavier becerra
about whether the department of health
and human services was aware
of american athletes falling ill after
returning from the military games in
wuhan
and he joins us now senator thank you so
much for joining us
really do appreciate it um what do we
know but what do we want to know uh
michael burgess there that we heard is a
doctor
uh but canada candidly uh
china has not really been forthright in
what's going on
you know you're right jason and i i know
if you'll go back to your days as
chairman of the oversight committee
when you can smell a cover-up and this
this smells like a cover-up every day
the timeline gets
backed up you know realizing that that
the middle of january the chinese the
world health organization were saying
there was no person-to-person
transmission now we know people in the
united states had positive antibodies in
december of 2019.
we know that the wuhan was starting to
cover up
this particular incidence as well in
october 2019
thousands of soldiers from hundreds of
companies gathered in wuhan china for a
military olympics
several weeks later they all many of
them developed symptoms
additionally they described wuhan a city
of 11 million people
as a ghost town so really since at least
october the people of china were
covering this up
and what i want to know as a senator is
is why didn't the cdc check into this
why didn't the hhs
check into this why wasn't intelligence
working on this
were they part of the cover-up do they
have some guilt uh
in the situation as well so i'm just
stunned to find out this new information
every week now the biden administration
is warning that we may never
quite know for with certainty what's
happening
but what are they doing if anything that
you can see from your perspective as a
united states senator
to actually push the chinese regime to
actually being more candid and
forthright with our investigators
well certainly not enough they do have
an investigation underway but i'm not
expecting them to find anything that i
that we don't already know
jason what this reminds me of is you
know you arrest the godfather
and all the witnesses start dying and in
this case
the witnesses though are the genomic
banks that we have setting out there
so in january of 2020 uh february of
2020 the nih re erased 500 genetic
sequences from the bat lady
that she was storing in the in the nih
laboratory bank
uh going back to 2019 in september
the bat lady erased a bunch of viruses
from the wiv
laboratory bank that we had access to so
the witnesses are all dying
there may be something though on the on
the cloud server that we can dig up
we're finding bits and pieces everywhere
but what we have to do is start holding
china accountable we can certainly we
can sanction them
we can seize their assets but what they
need is public shaming
that we have to shame them and not just
the united states but we need other
countries to shame them as well
we need to start bringing in product
lines manufacturing back jobs back to
the united states
do all those things to publicly battle
them
how what sort of confidence level do you
have in the world health organization
china made a big deal trying to get into
the world health organization
but now that they're there there are a
lot of people that are concerned about
the conflicts of interest that they have
well unfortunately the world health
organization has a very bad reputation
that they've been bought and paid for by
china
the leader of the world health
organization is a hand-picked person
from china
you know china's not dumb they they went
into uh
tedros is his name and went into his
country they looked they loaned the
money like
like a loan shark loans you money and
they got him this position as head of
the world health organization they
certainly have failed
and this is why we need uh whether it's
the quad or the g7 or the g20 but we
need multiple nations looking into this
and holding china accountable and then
starting the shaming in some way they
should be ashamed
that they invented this bioterrorism
with a weapon they should be ashamed
they leaked it from the lab
they should be ashamed that they covered
it up maybe they should be ashamed they
can't even make a vaccine right now
so this public shaming has to come to
fruition
so the concern is that the biden
administration is giving this some lip
service
but not actually doing anything listen
to what the former director of national
intelligence
john ratcliffe had to say about this
when he spoke with maria barto-romo
recently
what should be the accountability that
you'd like to see as a result of
the ccp allowing this deadly virus to
escape its borders and why
hasn't biden brought up the origins of
covid with xi jinping
now six months into his term
yeah as you know maria after the
election
um i wrote an op-ed calling china our
number one national security threat and
talked about
as the person who's seen more
intelligence than anyone in the country
for the past year
just how clear it is that they are not
just an
adversary but someone that wants to
supplant us as the world superpower
and my hope was that as we shared that
intelligence with the incoming
biden folks that they wouldn't just have
tough rhetoric on china
that they would have tough actions and
clearly that's not been the case
your reaction senator well jason your
listeners need to realize that china
wants to own the world that is their
goal right now you
and as you pointed out many times they
steal 500 billion dollars of
intellectual property from us every
every year 90 of the counterfeits and
the fentanyl that come into our country
are made in china
uh it's it's it's maybe exponentially
worse than i expected when i got into
the house and now
now the senate as well we do have to
hold them accountable but it's going to
be painful
it's going to be painful for this
country and for the world to say look we
cannot do
business with you when you lie when you
cheat when you steal from americans so
we're going to have to have some really
tough love
when it comes to dealing with china
focus on again bringing these supply
chains
back to the united states we have to
start by doing that yesterday
very quickly senator before we go to
commercial break the eco health alliance
that marina maria bradaromo has talked
about extensively
our government gave them an awful lot of
money there's a lot of suspicion there
you know exactly if i could call one
witness to our bipartisan health
care health committee i would like to
call peter dasik who heads that
we do need to follow the money it wasn't
just money from nih but also the
department of
defense was giving him tens of millions
of dollars as well
and really they were researching bio
terrorist wizard weapons
i think that this coronavirus is cobit
19 fits exactly into a man-made virus
you know when we look at this virus it
looks like something that frankenstein
would have made
so we got some some deep deep holes to
dive into
you're right follow the money all right
senator stay right there because
democrats are aiming to expand social
programs and pay for child care health
care and climate change
with tax hikes will they be able to push
it all through
using reconciliation we'll dive into
that next with the senator stay with us
[Music]
do you think he has the support of all
democrats will he be able to push this
through
reconciliation regardless of what the
republicans say
well i think it's going to be a long
hard slog for them to try to
increase taxes by this much on the
american
public for things that really would go
way beyond what i would think
is in the scope of government there are
so many liberal programs in here very
expensive the whole
green bad deal with the recyclable
cafeteria trays
i think he's going to have a hard time
doing it and it's not going to happen
quickly that's wyoming senator john
barrasso on president biden's
spending plans and challenges they face
in congress
a nearly one trillion dollar
infrastructure deal struck by a
bipartisan group of senators
has some potential but democrats also
want to include
include a lot of items from a 715
billion dollar
transportation and water infrastructure
bill passed by the house last week
we're back with kansas republican
senator roger marshall
uh senator are they going to be able to
pass this through reconciliation
i mean how do they justify all these
numbers because they keep adding the
trillions upon trillions
yeah jason first of all you better grab
your wallet because joe biden's
administration wants in that wallet of
yours
wants you to write big checks to them
but but look i i think they've spent
most of their political capital on this
you know a saying my dad taught me fool
me once shame on you fool me twice
shame on me and the biden white house
has now
fooled us three times and they threw a
bunch of senators under the bus
including democrat senators joe manchin
and kirsten cinema
uh you know joe gets most of the of the
ink but kirsten's one of the sharpest
people
i've met in a long time she wants to be
known as a maverick in that john mccain
model
she's been able just to balance i've
seen her take notes uh take some
some conversations with four or five
senators at a time
and then i would speak to her about a
deep health care issue
and she'd be able to recite the whole
thing back to it so i don't think
kirsten and joe
and the moderates in that party are
going to be happy about the way they got
through under the bus here and they're
not going to be happy about raising your
taxes
senator candidly one of my concerns is
republicans seem to worry about the debt
and deficit but only when they're in the
minority
so if you look back over the last 10
years
uh when it was obama biden if you look
at the spending money
and the base budget that that number is
really up nearly
more than 50 percent this is the
domestic base spending doesn't include
any of the other
stimulus and all the other things that's
the 10-year number
and then if you look at the debt it's
basically doubled
in that 10-year period and look
republicans had control for some of
those years
and the concern is we talk about how
much
more we're going to spend but senator
when are we going to actually have a
discussion about what we're going to
cut and curb back yeah well jason
certainly as long as democrats control
the white house
and control the house and the senate
that conversation is not going to happen
they've already borrowed what
uh two trillion dollars this year and
they want to borrow another six
trillion dollars so when i came to uh to
dc four years ago i thought we had a
plan
uh much like turning around a business
that's upside down the first thing we
had to do was grow the business so we
cut taxes
despite cutting taxes we actually grew
revenue for the federal government
and then you have to start dialing
things down and where are you going to
pick and choose i've yet to have anybody
call me up
and say hey i want you to want to cut my
my government subsidy
it's going to be a tough conversation to
have this is this is the problem that
keeps me up late at night
and whether you want a strong military
strong school strong roads and bridges
this this future of the balanced budget
is what's going to impact it more than
anything else so i agree completely but
it's a tough tough political
conversation to have
i think it'll take a second-term
president with a lot of confidence
well senator i think you're right when
you actually cut taxes the revenue to
the treasury went
up but if you don't couple that with
cutting spending then you
continue to exacerbate the problem and
americans are going to feel things here
real soon they're also feeling it at the
gas pump
where price of gas is basically a dollar
higher than it was
a year ago but senator i wish you
nothing but the best
uh this uh independence day i hope you
your family
and the good people of kansas have an
opportunity to celebrate like the rest
of america
because you know what this is still the
greatest country on the face of the
planet but we got to figure this one out
thanks jason great to be with you happy
independence day to you your family
and all your listeners thank you thank
you all right senator
appreciate your time